hello everyone
welcome to this tutorial on percentiles
and quartiles in statistics by simply
learn
in this tutorial we are going to learn
what is percentile and how we can
calculate the percentile
with the formula then we will move on to
qualitize and we'll see
what are qualities and how we can
calculate the quartiles with help of
formula
so without further ado let's get started
we'll start with percentiles so what
exactly is the percentile
a percentile is a term used in
statistics to express
how a score compares to other scores in
the same data set
while there is technically no standard
definition of percentile
it's typically communicated as a
percentage of values that fall below a
particular value
in a set of data scores percentage are
commonly used to report values from a
non-reference
test the formula to calculate a
percentile is px
is equal to x n plus 1 divided by 100
where x is the percentile you want to
calculate and n is the total number of
observations
let's understand this formula better
with the help of example
so how to calculate a percentile suppose
you have marks of 20 students
here we have the marks of 20 students 89
78 94
and so on the marks are scored out of
hundred
let's try to find out the 90th
percentile
so the first step to calculate the 90th
percentile is to sort the data in an
ascending order
so here we have sorted the data in
ascending order from 43 45 45
till 97.
the next step is to substitute the
values in the formula
so p90 will be equal to 90 20 plus 1
divided by 100
but 90 is the percentile you want to
calculate and 20 is the number of
observations
it should come to 1890 divided by 100
which will be approx to 94.
so our 90th percentile is a 94 marks in
the data set
what exactly does this 94 marks
signifies
p90 equal to 94 means that the 90 of the
students got less than 94 marks
and the 10 percent of the students got
the marks more than 94.
there's an another way to calculate the
percentile let's see how we can do that
suppose we want to calculate at what
percentile range the 78 marks fall
so to calculate this we have the formula
p is equal to small n divided by capital
n
into hundred where small n is equal to
ordinal rank of values and the capital n
is equal to total values in the data set
so substituting the values in the above
formula we get 12 into 100 divided by 20
which will be equal to 60 so this means
that the 78 mark signifies the 60th
percentile in the data set
now that we have discussed the
percentiles and know how to calculate
the percentile
let's move on to quartiles what are
quara tiles
quartile as a name suggest is a
statistical term that divides the data
into the four quarters
it basically divides the original data
points into the fourth quarters on a
number line
the q1 which is also called the first
quartile as the 25th percent of the data
set
the second quartile which is q2
signifies the 50 percent of the data set
and the third quartile which is q3
signifies 75
on the data set the q1 is also called a
lower quartile and upper quartile is
also called as q3
25 of all the data has a value
less than equal to q1 second quartile
which also the median
has 50 percent of all the data less than
m
75 of all the data has a value less than
equal to q2
and the 50 of all the data lies between
q1 and q3
if the measurement falls on the right
side of the upper quartile in a set of
data
then we know that it is in the top 25
percent of the data
if the measurement falls to the left of
the lower quartile of a set of data
then we know that it is in the bottom 25
of the data now that we have discussed
the theoretical aspect of quartiles
let's understand how we can calculate
the quartiles for this we have taken one
famous example let's consider that we
have the petal length of rose flowers
here we have the petal length in
centimeters to find the q1 q2 and q3
we first need to sort the data in
ascending order
so when you sort the data in the
ascending order we get the
following values 1.1.3 1.5
till 5.6 to find the m we have two
formulas
first when the n is odd and the second
when the n is even
since here the n is odd which is equal
to 15 will calculate the median by n
plus 1 by 2
which will be 16 by 2 which is equal to
the eighth value in the data set
so the q2 is the eighth observation
which is equal to 3.3 in the data set
to find the first quartile value we have
the formula q 1 is equal to n
plus 1 into 1 by 4 n plus 1 because we
have the
n as odd which is equal to 15. so
dividing 16 by
4 we get the value equal to 4. so q1 is
a 4th observation is equal to 2.0
so this point is our first quartile now
to calculate the q3 which is the top 25
percent of the data set
we multiply the n plus 1 into the 3x4
so q3 is the 12th observation which will
come out to be 4.2
so we have our q1 which is the first
quartile 2.0
q2 the second quartile which is also the
median at 3.3 and we have the q3 is
equal to third quartile
which is 4.2 so what does this point
signifies
one by four or twenty five percent of
the flowers have a petal length
that is less than or equal to two point
zero fifty percent of the flowers of the
petal length that is less than or equal
to three point three centimeter
three by four or seventy five percent of
the flowers have a petal length that is
less than or equal to 4.2
and half which is also 50 of the flowers
have a petal length between 2.6
centimeters and 4.2 centimeters
so with this we come to the end of this
tutorial on percentiles
and quartiles and statistics i hope you
like this video if yes please subscribe
our channel
and keep learning thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here